of minnesota has filed a civil rights
charge against the minneapolis police
department over the death of george
floyd
the investigation will look back 10
years for signs of
systemic discrimination this comes as
george floyd's family and friends
continue to push for justice jamie yukas
is following the story
in minneapolis where she spoke with
floyd's six-year-old daughter
and her mother he just
didn't scare her for roxy washington
seeking justice for george floyd is only
part of the tragic story
he loved god he loves children
he loves his kid what are you going to
miss most about him
washington is the mother of floyd's
six-year-old daughter
gianna who is now
without a father i pray
when she grows up she never run across
the fridge
we asked gianna what she loved most
about her father
he used to carry on his back all the
time
was that fun uh-huh it was super fun
what was fun about it um it's like you
feel the sky
like an airplane what would he say to
you
well he loved me a lot gianna heard the
news of her father's death on television
she said how did he die and i said he
couldn't breathe
this young lady is traumatized forever
it's not going to go away
it has changed the trajectory of her
life justin miller is washington's
attorney
he's joining protesters around
minneapolis and the country
calling on all four officers involved in
floyd's death
to be charged and convicted even though
he says
it will never be true justice you can't
put a value on a on a father you're
never bringing him back
never and you can't put a value on it
it is a priceless thing that far too
many uh
black children in this country are are
dealing with the loss of
washington says she's speaking up so
that this
never happens to another family again i
have the beast
because that's what he wants me to do
do you hope that there's change so that
she grows up in a different world
that there's change we got targets on
our backs
and it's the truth
the floyd family attorney told cbs news
they're expecting charges to be filed
against the other three
officers involved as for the minneapolis
police department
the chief says it will cooperate with
the state's human rights commission's
investigation
gail jamie yukas
that was tough thank you very much what
little girl doesn't like to be carried
by her daddy like an aeroplane i saw a
bittersweet moment
with with his daughter and someone asked
her what does your daddy do and she said
my daddy changed the world
she's six years old boy thank you very
much jamie yukas